[Music]  the state of nevada is issuing a warning  after the i-team shed light on a growing  problem  unlicensed group homes a special unit of  metro was created to look into  unlicensed group homes back in 2019  these are homes where people who have  special needs like dementia or other  health problems  are living to date our state is  investigating 26 complaints of  unlicensed  group homes that's since the start of  this year and police are in disbelief  over the conditions in some of them  no heating no air condition bed bugs  infestation  rodents no running water no working  bathrooms where they'll stack  10 15 20 people in and remember these  people  all need a higher level of care  those 26 complaints in nevada so far  this year come on the heels of  68 in 2020 and 62 in 2019.  you can file a complaint by calling the  number on your screen  702-486-6515  we also have a lot more information in  those i-team stories on this subject on  eight newsnow dot com